starting let's wait for our good friends
at YouTube to let us know what's going
on right it's receiving content good and
we are lives
welcome to the aisle or podcast and the
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
122 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable and the
Lord's Day I'm very excited about our
special guests and we've got Gamescom
recap control early impressions xbox
game studios exclusives whether they
stay exclusive its saudi acquiring is
Omni active discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord who I first met at PAX East it was
content I came across through fellow
stream team lead lost now though not
only is this Lord of rare beacon of
positivity in our game immunity
he's also the epitome of philanthropy
and education with his outstanding
charity streams and sound advice for
streamers everywhere
introducing the creating host of the
Daniel Tosh twitch channel official
strategy guide author and public
relations for the gaming community Expo
owner of the best mustache in the game
and always it always reminds us to stay
positive play more games and rework
outings live from San Diego and making
his debut into the realm of the Lords
mahmud Lord Donald Tosh how you doing
sir yo yo that's that's um I'm doing
great now
[Laughter]
words coming out of somebody you know we
always since you switched it's got to be
a huge fan of your content it's only
right we show your proper respect in the
realm I know you're playing a lot of
Minecraft anything else you can play my
off-time I'm getting too hardcore into
it
Wow is coming up nice nice I'm only
playing that because my friends are
playing it's like peer pressure Lords
podcast do not condemn pure fresh I'll
be playing I'm playing I'm playing
control the night Savas gonna like you
he's got that a early edition it's dope
dude you got to play it at at Guardian
make it all right it was that Guardian
con that's right my boy my boy now star
running that whole that whole program
there mm-hmm
well then that no I'm just like you know
just dip it into a little bit of
everything and I'm playing so much
minecraft as the community wants it so
badly that it's just been taking up all
my time
it's something new with Minecraft cuz
I'd be seeing like a surge going through
that
game yeah I mean it's magic like they do
exactly what they were doing they
brought out one of the biggest updates
they had in a long time during like the
most dead of video game seasons like
right before it was ramping up so people
like oh we better look out for Dame's
but nothing's coming out okay here's the
new minecraft version 1.1 4 and it's
like well everybody jumps on it and then
since since a couple things jumped on
with some bigger streamers and bigger
youtubers playing it again - it just
like blew up man yeah I have forbidden
myself to play minecraft - addicted to
they did yeah it really is that well
yeah it's one of those things where you
do a project he's like you know what
this looks amazing took me four weeks to
do be you know would look crazier what a
digital chore right beside it anyway
lots to talk about Lord downs in a bill
and we got some shorter good on and of
course we have beloved IOP family in the
realm fellow - lover wielder of the ILP
banhammer and protector of guinea pigs
everywhere
I'm just Susi talking about introducing
the I love podcast dream team liebe ILP
first-look creator and host of thus now
don't twitch channel Lord haw-haw
himself from strong eyelid Lord BT how
you doing sir I'm doing great I'm so
much better than I was last week I was
like just like king I was always in the
bushes and it seems every day I'll say
it must feel better playing with three
other people that was there
we blame an illness on a game told you
how to stay away from this is that IOP
after doing a commercial like the
commercial that we hosted Oh Lord PD
what have you been playing sir oh man
interesting week I actually played a
bunch of different games I ended up
playing well division 2 obviously
obvious obviously every day no man sky I
did a little bit of short strip to the
earth which was actually a lot more fun
that I thought it was going to be and
remnants of the ashes I got a little mom
in that you know what cinematography of
it it's great I really really loved that
part of it I really thought that coming
here mean for me personally I did not
expect it to be dark souls ii as Dark
Souls yes then I'm good looks like am I
actually gonna play this is it gonna get
the refund because I'm probably not
gonna play it anymore
so yeah other than that I would sell
everyone go get it you know there it was
it's actually really good if you liked
our souls if you like Socorro died twice
pick it up cuz you're gonna you're gonna
be loving it but what it really is now
because I believe it again after all the
patches after all the stuff and I really
think wow I thought it actually that the
base building and everything was way
really cool like for me I never played
it yeah before so like when I saw the
the the coop
even more so actually I was with danos
community doing it with a couple of the
other guys and being able to like you
know see someone else's bass and being
able to like actually look them in the
face and stuff I thought that was really
cool I think that you know it's very the
Lord dad singing the child find out
super Chad thank you sir
lots let's have a great show Xbox is the
best box but League of Legends have
stuck its claws in me again
it's fine filled with save me with gears
5 salute that's a good man we have a
seat over the wall let's go to death
everything good anyway moving right
along you know we have the Four Horsemen
of gaming those original Lords of the
realm here at the round table my co-host
for the colos my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of reviews and the half of the young
wolf mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir see they
know that that's the sin of our interest
oh this thing for destiny this solstice
whatever it's all the heroes baby let's
get that masterwork let's go I don't
know come on man give up now you got two
days come on to day two days go boy you
wanted to wait to cross save you got
your xbox there there's gonna be a lot
of stuff going on on my channel here
tonight yeah catch into that absolutely
mani reviews coming up yeah I'm gonna be
reviewing that um manova Dean or
whatever oh yeah yeah I saw yeah I
really liked those games like I really
do like I actually really like control
you planet you play no I was about to
say but your unfortunately continue
continue continue but you know it's it's
it's been a it's gonna thing yeah and
you know I definitely want to have like
a moment of silence real quick for King
oh you know King we have to remind
ourselves for some
this eleven o'clock eight nonsense this
bass baby let's get it to September 8th
to be fair I think we need a mourning
period we got two more weeks before 1
p.m. goes away temporarily for about two
months
good lord can't compete with anybody now
we do a play will end early relax
no no we're not doing a full season most
people's teams get eliminated after the
halfway point
Susie Azzam dies down yeah exactly my
nineties are out there we have the Lord
the solo gamer who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also
disaster Davis mr. or flower profile
Illuminati and lore patreon of the iron
bake Mahmoud Lord sovereign how you
doing sir I'm good man chillin nice
shorts name you like it yeah you guys
pulled me away from control I'm not
feeling this oh there was a big huge
podcaster d'oeuvre love ya dude
everything big shout out to mr. Lee
means favorite person in the world
[Applause]
why you got the fraud alert cake please
explain why
mr. Lee is like come to think of it I
really hope this man is not named mr.
Lee cuz you know the guy data we used to
grow up with we used to get our games
from the South Prague so it's like you
know sometimes he would get games early
so you know yeah that's like it was
every time is everyone trying to be nice
[Laughter]
you know he's one bully in the yard and
toughen you up for life yeah all right
well mr. Lee's the bully in the gaming
space are you saying you got bully king
listen I'm telling you he is the
original game stop before game yeah you
can literally walk out his store to game
you just purchase and you brought it for
$60 and walk right out the door and come
right back in and see now now let me get
that of the game over - I'll take that
that will be $5 that brand-new game you
got for me he would be value you he
would definitely you learn the ins and
out of game trade Emily you learned the
harsh realities of the devalued only
time you really see him the only time
you really see him is when you know a
big game has come out he's behind the
cat he's managing everything behind the
counter his face changes we come back
looking to exchange your game for not
making me your you're starting to make
me think this dude belongs on
supernatural or something like this
he's a busy around us do you be afraid
and take your games back to come out of
there yeah you took a console to him in
a couple of games you come out with two
games maybe sir and of course returning
from sickness we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka
the excess gamer the timing was the
timing supposed to be better but you
know how me and you wrapped the lord of
combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert beloved Lord that's fine I got
this chair this drink in these bushes
I'm cool you get into it we gotta hit
the super cherub nurse Wow for the 20
thank you so much $20 super chat shout
out to the Lord stuck at work but
finally got to catch you live but loving
you guys since I first heard y'all on
booze pasta podcast talking about mr.
Lee it imports thank you brother B so
much possible opt in the chest although
is he isn't around he asked me to say
FYI kick Oh sir cold the law vs. nothing
yard yesterday and the reason why I
didn't do the fight is because it was in
Russia and by the time you heard the
show the results was in I went to a
level round knockout yard wasn't ready
I was at least four fights away from
actually eating Koloff he gave all off a
star and test Kovalev showed that the
old lion still has some fangs push back
the young cub I thought that the young
cub definitely was at a disadvantage you
know you offer the young cub a big bag
early in his career but he's still green
and you take him out early as a Floyd
Mayweather tactic Lennox Lewis has done
it to perfection
and I think yard should have had
somebody in this corner because all
money is not good money right so let's
get back to what's going on I am so
happy to be here guys hit me in the DMS
I love all the colors in the chat you
guys make me sing my heart was bleeding
last week energy base I can hear it I
can hurt you
oh man I when Khan called me I was like
attendance is impeccable if you don't
rested take the show off please I'd
rather you healthy a good man but you
sound great I was done but all week I
was taking tumeric shots all week garlic
shots all week making sure that I got
back to the show what I was playing or
we doing all right so you know you see
the arcade machine on the side over here
I could see it through like that I was
playing a whole bunch of old-school
games so what I got on to is I'm going
to just you know take a lot of videos
posted during the week you let me know
hit me hit me a regular on Twitter
Matney and I'm gonna find your favorite
gaming is 6900 games in it and I'm you
know Morita feel yeah I like that
Simpsons game foot of the Spider Man
old-school arcade game real quick set a
cage thank you so much brother $10
subject
showing some love before clockey and
that's where I can get the Lords at work
man Sunday that's what's up thanks man
continue
salad lady loca and building nothing can
keep King down it's it's fine there's
not a lot of people to get see Luka when
she's buying two steering wheels
oh stop it stop it nothing could keep
dig down shout out to the Lord's love
you guys and everything you do shoutout
to the skunk a sucker pay attic know my
Luca we don't get him we get you a will
ro static don't you know I was playing
try to claim that three times when you
were there saying about how many cases
[Music]
not make it to the end of the game guys
and play it it is probably one of the
most artistic games I've played so far
this year the fact that it's free inside
game past it's an equal bonus if you've
ever played journey you like absolutely
love this game it's it's very good and
also it's for everybody of all ages so
if you know children your children can
play it with no problem now there's
another game on the other end of that
spectrum that your children can
definitely not watch like it's ruiner
[Music]
you're that key is it's such a visceral
feel when you able to speed - all across
the board like the flash it's line up
behind each enemy shoot them in the back
of the head and then bang them with a
pole wasn't any splat or they stick all
over it is a visually pleasing game the
sound is great and the feel and the
control of the game is a mess it is a
very good game all these stuff is in
game pass I played more games I'm not
gonna get into all that other stuff but
uh shout out to dizzy
Petty's going a little bit better just
shave or those not seeing the sins of
King the bed Oh soft be it is tithing
Sunday at a collection plate hashtag
like it's obscure this bag comes in here
to make sure you pay but real quick dose
salute that did y'all make sure y'all
send him some love he's going through
some Medicare tough you know I'm saying
it's on the mend
that's our Lords of gaming dotnet
editor-in-chief please the man is
healing up and still finds a way to get
into the podcast and show some love you
I don't like myself and last but not
least we have myself the Lord of the
cooperative experience and gaming nation
the shinobi lore Cognito spread
narrowness into the realm of the IOP now
tell me what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so for me it's all
about destiny to cross Savior I was so
happy man this was literally the moment
I've been waiting for I'm being shadow
keep is nice I'm excited for that but
this was actually the feature I was most
excited got everything to work you know
I'm saying and moving my characters over
from Xbox to place a PC feels good to
have all that good stuff man tremendous
feature so I was doing that on what else
I was doing here
NBA 2k 20 demo drop messing around with
that a little bit um of course more for
a little bit more Fire Emblem you know
I'm saying doing that
dragons very impressed I've never played
a game before because it was played at
the DMV we got a lot of show to get into
it shows very long but now that we got
into what the Lord's are playing I want
to start with his video game system
history his journey as an author and
streamer and of course what led him to
working with charities like extra life
st. Jude and of course PR for guardian
Kong now known as gcx from Lord I know
for the very beginning like what was the
first video game system she had and what
Gatchina gave me well I mean like a
legit my my grandmother was my was my
birth into into video games man we had
wish we had Atari 2600 old-school stuff
playing the tab
devil game on the big fat TV let's go
big back with the big back TV the TV
that doubled as furniture in the house
oh yeah it looked like a jukebox in the
background like it was that thing was
huge man and yeah we had the Atari
hooked up to that and then she also had
like the original Gameboy yeah I was
playing like she played all these casino
games on there and I think I played I
played like Tetris and like a few other
things there Wow yeah but I've been
playing since I was you know I'm playing
games since I was like four because she
would she's watching me more might well
my parents went to work and stuff like
that so yeah wow that's a debate I think
it's the first like gravel I got you to
get a saw like she's still like she has
no idea what I do for a living she
doesn't understand it at all but she's
still like she's always talking she's
got her she got an Amazon Kindle Fire or
whatever playing all kinds of games on
that thing man legend my grandmother's
pretty young she's like in her she's in
her 70s now like I'm in my 30s and
that's just kind of how I go she's she's
pretty young but you know that's uh
she's how it goes
yeah yeah so from there and then went on
to SNES and Nintendo and then and then
stuck on the stuck on the PlayStation
side for a long time until I got my
first Xbox 360 what she happen to be 60
talk about it well 360s were actually a
lot of my gaming prowess came from it's
that's the only time in my life I
actually did something professionally
for a woman okay
played Call of Duty professionally and
like the MLG and colleagues Oh
use those people are they'll use those
that means he was a B when you're
rolling yeah you got six of your guys
all of the same clan tag and stuff that
like you changed your xbox they were
tagged to yeah that was that was us for
real and then we'd we'd gone to like
Vegas every now and then do some
tournaments Wow get extra sweaty there
and
mmm-hmm it was it was like like and I
was I was like 18 you know but I was I
was still like playing on those teams
with like since I was like 14 like it
was insane all through high school a
little bit through college mm-hmm then I
bought my first my first PC and then a
lot of generation just like the Lord's
but a lot of great systems at 26
video games have become my they've been
my entire life forever man like
legitimately it's it's been I mean I
mean I've been in this industry
professionally for not counting the
eSports stuff for 10 years now so it's
just been like video games just surround
my entire universe that's that's just so
also we've also known you precise
history like we also known you for these
strategy guys could you tell us about
that like how'd you get into that you
know I'm saying that aspect of the game
that actually the competitive history is
kind of what burden that as well
so I played on the team for a long time
played on and played on two different
teams one on PC and one on xbox two
completely different teams didn't know
each other it's just like I played twice
and then that was like you know
everybody was like super sweaty and
everybody's yelling at each other and
trying to get better and better and I
was like I don't I'm getting too old for
this I'm like 19 years old I'm Way too
old for this so I was like okay so I'm
gonna go find another team which the
next thing I found was was not nearly as
good by any means but we were still a
crew that stuck together actually like
I'm not gonna lie being on this podcast
right now it reminds me a lot of that
team because a lot of camaraderie and a
lot of time together and a lot of like
Brotherhood there
in fact I've got a poster i weirdly it's
right here oh let's go let's go bring
out the posters get it let's take it
back yes but we did run these we did a
signing event where Bator scream one
more time down so that people can see it
Wow call it the goal signing event
Wow that is that is me oh okay that's me
and like the ghost like you know that
from ghost that's me that's one of our
artists who actually is the leader of
our of our group who's an artist
personal artist that actually was in the
next part of the story mm-hmm
we were playing together we never really
did anything super professional for for
the gaming side of things but we are
leader rich who who
we started our website started the team
together and stuff like that he started
developing with one of another one of
our other web devs a online kind of map
tactical system to where you can bring
up any map in any of the Call of Duty's
or so Commons where we started and you
would you know the circuit you had to
actually go by the internet adapter for
your PSP yeah why not do that but yeah
we so he was like dude we need that we
need to draw up some of these things we
need to bring some stuff in we started
our own league and stuff like that's
where like I will send it to everybody
so he would actually go in and draw the
entire map using like the game shark to
fly up in the air and draw all that out
Wow and then piggyback which was an old
game strategy guide company it was like
hey we see these on here we see you
doing a bunch of stuff you were to come
in and like write a guide for us Wow so
they brought in like four or four the
old members of the team and went in with
a bit did their first SOCOM US Navy
SEALs to strategy guide and then they
just started pumping them out they
started like I asked him to come back
because they were actually like real
professional dudes yeah and then I
joined the team a little bit later and
they found out that my education is in
communication and writing and all this
stuff is like hey it's a sin amount I
was also local to the prima games studio
yeah so that was a game studio so I went
out there and talked with them had a
meeting and they're like hey you want to
go write it want to write a battlefield
piece for us and I'm like sure so
battlefield 4 is one of the first DLCs
that came out though like hey we just
want to do an online piece do that and
start writing it and they liked it and I
just kept coming back over and over
again until they finally gave me my own
fine my own book before they went under
Wow that's taking it back remember those
men prefer more efficient strategy guide
oh there you go Wow nice dice oh yeah so
yeah pretty much pretty much made that
one so but yeah I mean there's so many
books everywhere that they're just it's
a huge part of just being in the
industry was being able to to go into
these studios and actually like
interview a lot of these designers be
like yo what did you do how do we do
this how do we make it better and yeah
that's awesome so just out of curiosity
I don't want to like depart it like is
it so when you go to like do they give
you what's what I'm looking for
I've always wondered how a strategy
guide is actually like develop so like
do you do you just talk to the dev do
they give you do you have to ask them
everything or are they pretty open with
everything in their game for you to
write the guide we know everything you
know they're our job is to know
everything this is they bring us into so
like I did Star Wars Battlefront the
first one when when they relaunched in
in Redwood City so what we did is we
drove out to Redwood City we went to the
what we call ears ei Redwood City and
just sat in their office or sat in their
studio for I was there for three weeks I
played the game basically every day came
in on the weekends looked at everything
looked at absolutely everything recorded
I don't know like 60 hours of content
and then just went back like basically
we write notes and put all our stuff in
but we don't actually do any writing
bring all the recording back and watch
it all back and just start writing the
entire book oh yeah we're interviewing
like some of the producers we're
interviewing a lot of the designers and
stuff like that will talk to the QA like
hey what are some good strategies for
this well we'll play against the devs
for a while to figure out some good
things like wow but a lot of the time
especially we're doing multiplayer games
it's like me and my co-author
playing against each other so it's a one
on
it's supposed to be like 6960 we're
trying to figure out what actually works
there mm-hmm so we have to guess stuff
like that but you know it's a lot of
guesswork it's also a lot of like you
said interviewing and also just playing
the game for hours an hour that's really
cool
shoutout to tempest son would follow us
which I you guys are legit legends love
to show and to King how'd you like that
KD a statue I'm hoping to get it at some
point but it's kind of pricey okay you
know hit me I'll send me the exact
statue or whatever now go over with you
and I can go over ways on how to get the
statue at a cheaper price if you're
having problems in it
or give you different avenues to
actually you know doing layaway plans
and stuff like that and who can
facilitate those in the statue community
we have a lot of ties so maybe somebody
wants to let go of the statue at a
cheaper price other than what you're
seeing right now no doubt no doubt
so yeah moving no one would lower down I
want to talk about streaming aspect you
know that's what landlord Slough don't
put me on to you you didn't mean it
actually it was funny because when I
first met you it was during the katana
zero and I didn't know who you were
that's for full disclosure I did it was
PD educated me and I'm like oh I did it
he's like you know who did that video I
had no idea I'm treating Daddo like he's
just a regular random guy playing guitar
as a fan plant would you mind me
capturing some footage of you play it's
like sure I'm just a fan do you are so
cool and I look back I'm like oh my god
even realize who this but least I got to
redo myself a guardian cut a little bit
give you a proper introduction good yeah
I've seen a lot of people know you for
streaming the twitch thing you know I
mean the whole thing so just that whole
streamer life you know I'm saying like
how did that really start and then also
talk about your work with treatments
quick because I know um you've got up
there and stuff like that so tell me
about them
so screen for me started almost five
years ago about four and a half years
ago I had been so I had been an actor
I've been writing and strategy guides
and stuff like that like video games is
obviously huge for me and I was trying
to do like a lot of different recorded
content and putting it on YouTube and
stuff like that and it just wasn't it
wasn't necessarily working for me
because I was too much into the
production of like how it was gonna go
and then finally by the time I started
actually doing the work I was like well
now I'm exhausted I wanna do something
so I was like dude this is just too much
work and then and then old friend of
mine old now he was new then but he came
up to me and was like hey so he knew I
was podcasting for long time I should
say that for like years I did a lot of
comedy but if you if you are at all
interested in like you know yes just
just stuff like that that podcast the
reason the reason we named it that
podcast is because I did a bunch of a
bunch of shows before we actually like
released it was because I got to
interview some like badass people nice
my first interview is with my first
podcast the very first episode who is
with Ashly Burch who is tiny Tina from
Borderlands okay Wow also Janet Varney
who is Korra from Legend of Korra so
that was that was my first interview I
was like dude we got it like put this
out or do something with it and people
were like telling me like Dean you suck
dude yeah so so that's what it became
and then later people interviewed Peter
Cohen who's
he's Optimus Prime from transfer Oh like
Cohen yeah oh not gonna let you over
that is also the voice of men you
amazing amazing I mean it's just I mean
I'm gonna like truthfully I've had I've
been living my very my very best life
and like we live in my favorite life I
enjoy everything I do I love it
obviously you know times or times get
tough every now and then we struggle but
knowing that knowing all the people that
are behind me and they got my back and
they pushed me forward and all that
stuff like that's that's what keeps me
going for real so so that's like that's
what I've kind of developed this stream
around is is keeping that positivity up
and keeping everybody's everybody's hand
on each other's back pushing forward and
stuff like that long as you got that
crew behind you you can do whatever the
hell you want in your entire life and
that's it's kind of how it's become like
been with my girlfriend for almost six
years now and she's behind my back this
entire time my parents have no idea what
that what I do but they still support me
they've been separating since I was two
so they never been they have been never
been a team together but they've always
like separately had my back and
something like that so that's been a
huge help and and you know I've had I've
had my ins and outs like I grew up in
Oakland California have been oh you know
all that I've been I've been shot at
I've been I've been threatened to be
stabbed I mean
all that stuff like it's cheesing and
streetfighter yeah there's the light in
the dark and you know that balance once
you hit that balance and you become the
actual ultimate true gray Jedi and you
can actually take all that power and put
it into something solid just don't be
just don't be the Anakin of the world
believe your sensei by him having the
upper ground salut [ __ ] of medicine did
he got the book going on what it was a
shooting square how did you link with
those guys the whole like damn stream of
what kind of thing so actually that's
that's that's pretty that's pretty
recent too actually so one of the last
projects that prima games asked me to do
was hey we want to do what we want to do
a book on on Twitch and they're like
you're the person that I like you're the
person that really we know that we trust
cuz I've been working with them for
years we should do a book and I was like
that's like okay I only do the book if I
do it my way and they're like yeah
that's fine they they're like okay just
do this and then about midway through us
getting ready to release the book is
when they announced that they were
shutting down I was like damn but I want
to put out something that was super
powerful and so I I put together a
really quick outline I got one of my
good friends Kimberly who works at
Ubisoft to be my co-author and we put
again a bunch of interviews together
when we brought together this this
amazing amazing book that has all kinds
information in it yeah the big thing was
we found out we found a lot of people
really knew a lot of positive things and
really good things about how they how
they grew their their stream and their
YouTube in their everything
and we're like okay but they don't know
how to talk about it because it's not
easy right so I was like okay let's
figure out how to how to get all these
thoughts together and put it out there
in a way that people can understand and
we'll we bring in so we put that
together and then in that both Loco and
Hunter who are the two owners of
streamer square they're both in the book
in fact my producer was like hey can we
put one of hunch
quotes on the back and he's like yeah
I'll do it and he was super cool with
that
so we did all that and we I started
announcing that the book was coming out
and whatnot and both loco and Hunter
were like hey do you want to do you
wanna do a project with us and I was
like sure I've been thinking about doing
my own show like kind of like a book
club where we go through the book and
actually talk about different topics and
whatnot that's in there and we turned
the show into not only what the book was
about but being a professional in this
industry because this a lot of these
things that we see out there we see so
many people just straight up acting a
fool like it's just crazy sometimes and
really think about what it means to be a
professional in this industry as a whole
so for streamers for content creators of
all kinds for actual developers and
producers and community managers I try
to put together a program where
everybody can just listen to and
actually like put their thoughts into
what they're doing all the time and make
them a better professional in that way
so we put that show together and then
that became that became what it is now
and we're what 12 weeks into it now it's
pretty solid having some fun yeah real
quick Lord Lord Dan in the chest says yo
what Ubisoft location I was invited to
Ubisoft San Francisco a few years back
and met a lot of people I think he's
asking you Lord ana o friend of mine
yeah she works that she works at San
Francisco okay yeah she was the issues
with the Associate Producer for the
South Park the fractured but whole I
just like that technical turn-based
thing they've got me every time that
every time South Park makes something
I'm like man I know I'm playing it
though so I gotta ask this question
because we got lost I'll go in here Lord
dizzy in here started trouble Oh about
the whole mixer and twitch thing going
on right now
timeline oh you had some things to say
about it there you have some friends and
strong relationships on both sides but
you know especially after the ninja
you know transformation
he went over an exodus over there to mix
it like you know what's your feeling on
both platforms did you I feel like how
that was handled was done correctly and
just in general I know you you your
foundation is twitch but just overall
what's your feeling on this whole
situation oh yeah I mean if you've seen
my timeline you know that I don't I
don't care about loyalty at uni platform
right loyalty to our platform is just
and in my opinion is just ignorant and
arrogant we should all be we're all
content creators we all in this the same
exact world doing the same exact thing
all as one right so we're all doing the
same we're all working hard to be our
very best we possibly can so I think
everybody across all platforms no matter
what you're on we're all in this
together and this baby game is we're all
gamers exactly video game is bond
bags talk about it it's like I was
saying a couple day weeks ago when
Walmart try to pull that we're not going
to so violent video games and the time
it took that your work gives you much
break a bruise lashed out to them they
change they mind we met a multi-billion
dollar corporation with a bunch of
tweets like okay like we're stronger
together than individual people together
but continue Katella diddle
know so like the big point what that was
was I don't I still don't know through
this day and I know ninja decently well
like I've I met a couple of times we've
had long talks like he where he's very
close with all the the Guardian cons ECX
boys know pretty well and stuff like
that and I I don't know I still don't
know to this day why or what the big
reason for it was I'm here there's a
paycheck involved whatever yeah but a
lot a lot of it might has to come with
probably long term branding and product
placement and Microsoft being a team
that he wants to be back of and that's
that's all good what it would have you
so that has probably a lot to do with it
I'm how it was handled was fine until
twitch decided to do what they did yeah
breaking stuff up yeah that stuff that
they did that was very underhanded but
understand you know it's business when
you take your biggest commodity and your
biggest commodity leaves or your biggest
face leaves and go someplace else I mean
it doesn't look good as on the brand I
just thought I thought it was poorly
yeah and I thought it was immature but
they got us in front of it and you know
they put out the statement you know the
algorithms posted it but it should
matter but they handled it quickly so
you take them at face value they didn't
expect that to happen and he didn't want
it to happen but that was some pettiness
that lupine they face once explain why
exactly why it was petty
yeah good cuz it was it was there was
there was no change in their stock when
ninja left they had already been showing
ninjas viewership declining in his
monetization kind of declining so they
weren't they weren't really worried
about him leaving it wasn't a big deal
somebody freaked out and made a couple
of pulled a couple strings and said hey
we needed to make this happen because if
we don't we're gonna lose out on tons of
money that we can make what have you mmm
and viewership so so stock never
declined really in any significant
matter viewership across the board did
not decline in fact it increased because
of the the actual release season coming
up and nothing really changed with him
leaving and going to a different
platform not to mention a week later we
saw that his his status on mixer and all
the the vias viewership didn't really do
anything after the initial launch so
nothing really happened so 26 days to do
anything would've felt like it felt like
they felt like he was entitled to their
platform like if you're leaving this is
if we made you that's what it felt like
to me like fortnight made him but sure
exactly I'm not saying that's that's
true I know anything no like that's what
they were saying real quick just a
backtrack one second one down average
giant he's asking Donal he said he
missed the name of the book can you put
the bar up one more time to the screen
so people could see he'd be very
interested it's grown stanitch it's
called twitch creating growing and
monetizing your live streams you can
find it on amazon.com or Twitter Target
calm no doubt no doubt
there you go average giant straight from
the legend himself no but I hear you
Mary we definitely agreed we didn't like
the way you know it was handled and all
that good stuff but um last but not
least I'm gonna move on his arm
x-men where I got the chance I get to
bump into you you know on we know you
are P R which I was proud to know learn
that day when I'm talking you and yeah
man like so formally Guardian Khan you
know how did you get involved that
literally one of my favorite events and
my shout-out to my co-hosts from the
last word that's literally where I met
Ibanez maybe the second Guardian Khan
every record is destiny Connelly and yes
that's the community car over at the
Tampa Bay what is it the fairgrounds
fairgrounds yeah no yeah it was a
beginning a sweaty bar with 300 people
mmm and they brought out a thousand so
they kind of said hey we need to do
something bigger because this is
apparently what happens so you have you
have the boys right it was when we call
them you have king of Bali and Cory Ben
who's professor broman and then you had
Kevin caveman or one recently added Tim
darkness yes from Facebook he's worried
streaming on Facebook now so you have a
lot of different platforms that have
come together to make one so basically
is a bunch of a bunch of bunch of
destiny guys including t-rex is he back
Superman's brother and and also an
amazing streamer what a good friend of
mine but so we're all kind of we're all
actually actually everybody in that
group we're all managed by the same
management company online performers
group cool so we we kind of had a
connection already through a lot of that
and a lot of those guys are friends
already but I've been I've known
professor broman for about three or four
years now and then we've had a couple
conversations and I was able to connect
him a couple connections way back down
the road about something I don't really
remember what it was and he seemed to
really like the way I was able to talk
to people and put things together and
actually put you know names out there
for people that oh I read what it's for
so I did a Madden strategy guide I did
two mad at Treasury way back in the day
and the professor Burma and wanted to
bring out like some some football
players and some NFL players to Guardian
con like two or three years ago was like
okay I'll make a connection whatever and
then he really likes that we did it and
and I was like do you need can I do
anything else for regarding calm can I
do
to help because it's a charity
convention so we're like can I help the
kids because I mean we were getting to
that later I'm really big into charity
he's like well we really need somebody
that can do some like public relations
and show off like some of the things
we're doing to the gaming gaming avenues
and some of the people that write like
Kotaku and polygons and stuff like that
mmm like yeah let me see what I can do
and it turned out that I was able to get
you know able to get Guardian turn on
the news and Tampa put them in the
newspaper and stuff like that so it
really like spread the word and we kind
of went from there
bro that's evil that way that's awesome
because a lot of the reason why it drew
me any montes is that I don't think the
Destin community got enough credit for
the work that they did was st. Jude and
like that whole big coming together and
how much they raised each year you know
I'm saying four is tremendous and just
to see that level of exposure for that
finally you know the community getting
current credit and I like to do the
whole slogan like gaming the good in
gaming you know saying that is really
good yes yes I love that slope when I
walked in the first thing I seen and it
was tremendous man just to see like I
said your involvement with it was really
really brilliant it's my big fight right
now because the the general and American
media can't stay off of video games
being violent conductors and I'm like
you do you serious if you see how many
millions of dollars raised do it for AJ
brother preaching you not only fight
that fight with you like that even does
good and we wonder we want to show that
preach man it's a billion dollar company
industry wrap up we got more stop any
questions lost l don't mean anything for
the legend is this your man in the bill
this is your moment moment we talk every
day every morning like good Danna we'll
be streaming and I'll I'll hit up when I
get into the office of work I'll just be
like what's up morning how's it go and
we have our conversation so we had them
back before the Discworld
[Music]
I can tumble read also if you want it's
a joke Barrow is that PDL he doesn't
have any other color ILP shirts he
literally does but he loves the red one
the C's Lord roll extremely important
life or death class on destiny oh yeah
we what are you I'm a danger boy you are
doing so it's all play would tie that
just disqualifying crucible and I'm
lightning fist I'm just gonna take this
shot the bad bit gaming's warlock 1000
my second my second class is a hunter
embrace the because of
what's funny is when you use a war like
you got to like learn your own language
okay if I jump here am I gonna make it
this one can I make it to this rock if I
jump to this rock at times like I'm just
gonna jump over at all warlocks beat me
the most in PvP we got other slo-mo I
never played destiny but when I do I
play as a warlock get you before we go
is on into the topics is I ask everyone
I need Lord down are you ready
we need the top five your top five video
game of franchises of all oh my my
number one see I fight with number one
number two right now
my number one is gotta be still enter
the gungeon and that took over my
Knights of the Old Republic love talking
about that yesterday cause I know you
like Star Wars because I was telling
Lord kognito like the story is so dark
in eyes to the Old Republic that Disney
will never touch that with a ten-foot oh
no well they touch on great Jedi's and
great Jedi's are - they're too
complicated for the general audience
mmm so we got those two we get the other
ones like I go all over the place like I
like darkest dungeon is up there I like
Call of Duty - you know what else am I
looking at you know binding Isaac is not
it's not my top like in my top 5 but
it's in my top 10 like give me that last
one to round out the five I mean did I
mean what Dragon Age probably okay which
one which one or just a franchise in
general the franchise in general I like
the into the entire franchise
are you are you nervous for the
I can't I can't I can't wait to see it
but I also don't ever want it to come
out to lead producers in like three
months man like what's going on
dude like it's it's bad do you think
it's actually like be esophagus
conversation do you think it's a
situation we're just not the same by
where we grew up with you know it's not
at all
we know that for I know for a fact I'm
really close with a lot of yeah and I
know it's I know for a fact it's not the
same by oh oh there's so many people
leaving it's not the same team anymore
oh it has EA has their fists right in
their throat it's it's gross like you
know it's like terrible inside
information like it's not the same I
mean how much flak like because EA is so
sensitive to online flak that the amount
that they got for the last Mass Effect
Andromeda and the amount of flak yeah
they gotta or for anthem yeah they just
they EA is just gonna they're gonna tear
em apart
that's what they can't do anything about
it yeah that's literally what being an
addict talked about would just work like
they can't have a third flop because at
this point EA could any other dev like
there's very few devs in this industry
they can get away with with with two
flops back-to-back like yeah and I think
you know by war just has that that cloud
that there all right you know we'll give
you Dragon Age but III you know just out
of curiosity cuz I was talking on this
about with Laura Cognito do you think
that if respawn you know has a
successful
what's that Jedi gank you forgetting the
name of that game or do you think if
that game comes out and it does really
good do you think that might you know
give EA little bit more inside how they
should run studios oh no because respawn
respawn is completely independent thank
you whatever the heck they do whatever
they want
thanks anytime EA says hey we want you
to do this they come to go I thought I
thought yeah bought them
oh no they own them but they don't get
to say anything because yes fun just
prints them money yes and you're easy
one makes them
millions of dollars in response says
we're gonna do whatever the hell we want
you guys can't say anything about it
it's really headed in their contract -
okay weird wait you got to leave us
alone because they saw what they ended
up doing with all the other games
respawn has never made a bad game and
they've been around since the beginning
one two three four I mean not three but
one two and four apex titanfall those
are two guys I wrote to trying for one
and two I've got the full helmet up here
and stuff because you know game stop but
I'm pretty well done I mean you know me
kognito and sovereign you know I can
definitely tell you off and we
definitely supported them and I was
talking about me - oh the one right
before just a big book mm-hmm it was
there any other like competition that
was making them with them like I know
primer did it was there another company
that did strategy guards yeah Grady
Grady like I know I know I was a big fan
of like the Elder Scrolls like there's
very few games that you know back when I
was like in my early teens I used to buy
all the poke of all ones with it yeah I
bought all the Elder Scrolls with all
the fallouts and what's funny is I never
used them adventure games we do mostly
in fighting game so therefore strategy
guide companies like major ones so the
fourth one I can't ever remember cuz
it's like a weird Russian name or
something then you had piggyback who did
like they did like seven guides a year
because they put so much work into them
and then you had Brady games and you had
prima games who were the two top
competitors
it's at one point the parent companies
so penguin and Random House the ones
that own Priya and Brady games they
combined so that means Brady and prema
combined it became one company and then
they were the kings and the Giants but
then everything kind of sort of fell
apart because like print was dying and
yeah they weren't keeping up with a lot
of online content like that so it was
becoming it became one big company for
about the last three and a half years
mmm and then and then so they finally
would not and that is one entity no I
think the industry was dying and I think
if they if they were to both stay
separate they would have cannibalize
each other faster so coming together
made them last a little bit longer but
they didn't keep up with everything
because they were so old school that
they yeah you know it almost feels like
IRA my guess you go ahead it was like it
almost feels like that era like it was a
specific time pocket with that strategy
guy you went got you used game you got
to strategy it was like part of the
process like when you went in you got
your game
you made sure that you got your strategy
guy and some some guys you know and
girls what will you do is go three right
and we'll play the game and then I saw
the hardback version for Final Fantasy
13 with the game some really like in
years but like well I ain't gonna lie
like when when they woulda had a
business like that actually hit me why I
was like man like it's changing man like
it really is that's one of the best ones
did you see the binding of it and you
see the gold around at the time the gold
right oh I'd even notice that that's
serious
I wonder I wonder if like certain
companies that so cuz I'm sure they
there were still certain games that so
like strategy guys I wonder if like the
companies will actually like in-house
make one well they made like so they
partner with these other companies in
fact prima games we did a lot of those
for them they partner with other
companies and they do them so like Dark
Horse that has a lot of Dragon Age stuff
mmm they do comic books obviously but
they do a lot of video games things as
well but yeah but I mean it's the it's
print is gonna is it until people
actually companion digital content with
it print will always die because if I
don't know how to do something
I literally pull it up my phone like in
completely right that's what killed me
like I'm okay with a lot of things dying
but those strategy guys hit me certain
I'm like you know like music going
digital games going digital audio going
digital I'm like oh it's whatever but
when those strategy guys look digital
it's like I don't know that it like I
can sure I can look up stuff I mean I
even make a lose on my youtube channel
but like there was nothing had like that
that weird feeling when you're flipping
through like a strategy guide and you're
looking at artwork and we're gonna do it
all the time that like you can see the
actual like hard sweat and tears that go
into the sovereign and I used to do was
what was the name of the website that we
used to go to okay thanks Kay facts
again facts first write binary talk and
then the strategy guides came out and
they were so much more visually
stimulating and it just completed the
package nicely especially that Skyrim
strategy yeah i have those holding up my
monitors right now
[Laughter]
1,000 he's he writes a lot what is the
biggest strategy guide that you've ever
wrote that I ever wrote I mean I worked
on The Witcher 3 guides but when I wrote
was probably I don't know try titanfall
2 honestly whoa
that or that or Dragon Age Inquisition
oh I had to get that discount my
favorite one is the Star Wars
Battlefront one because we gave away
these so if you ever get life you were
to get your hands on a collector's
edition one it's a soft touch cover so
it's actually like a soft like foamy
touch mhm and then we also gave the in
there there's full lithographs of the
planets and maps that were like what I
really meant I'd just said I wasn't
gonna detour okay when I saw those store
Troopers helmets on the stairs
I was like okay now I'm really thinking
like Disney is starting to realize that
okay we do have an audience that we bet
there are kids like we got be a little
bit more dark in certain areas should
run the IG assassin droids which those
those dudes mess people up like this
take on 13 to 1 in a lot of the books
they're crazy through the door and then
the door closed which who now is an
actor was an MMA fighter she's a piece
back beast
salute man look we gotta where we keep
low
sugar butter your silhouette tremendous
history tremendous top five let's get
into the rest of these tablets and the
show last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken
to the question when you hear of studio
leads of prominent development
departures prior to the launch of mataró
how concerned are you regarding the
quality of the title moving forward the
winner of a pretty close three-way ILP
poll is the yes I'm very concerned based
on the level of departure group coming
in at second place at 44% was no minimal
concern devs leaves jobs every day be
last place at only 3% where are shallow
Lloyd's I don't care until it's my
favorite studio group all the lords who
participated in the poll Lord sovereign
what do you think about this poll sir we
won yes concern that's right you were
adequate at it last week that's
different to go back and listen to you
guys's show right after bob was sleeping
but we were talking we got another poll
covered or at the end of the show let's
get into these topics Lord at it you are
up something happen in Germany man
Gamescom something happened in Germany
so you know anyone that's watching us
I'm sure you know we just said Gamescom
and you know what I want to go over
there's a couple things that happen at
Gamescom you know inside Xbox Jackie Lee
actually had a he put on a good show
like I really enjoyed his uh you know
what he presented there except for the
death strain I don't know what's going
on though
but uh you know going on there I want to
just you know talk about you know what
your general thoughts of Gamescom was
and what your highlight of the
your event was lieutenant Manuel
Gamescom not at the coverage kind of
winding down and everything like any
highlights any things that stood out for
you I mean I don't I see I found it I
find out about so many things before and
after it's like I don't even actually
know what it's even talked about at
Gamescom anymore good I know that I know
that they did they talk anything about
more scarlet stuff like that's the thing
I did see that they're still pushing out
borderland stuff I'm all my friends at
Borderlands or a gear box we're super
psyched they won like most anticipated
game at Gamescom yeah yeah oh yeah like
like there's a lot of people that are
looking forward to all those games and I
mean I'll tell you firsthand Borderlands
is it's okay I'm super excited for that
game because I've gotten to play like a
few hours of it it's it's real smooth
and it's real good so that's it's a good
one to be looking forward to for sure
absolutely but so Portland so on the
list got a chance to touch a little bit
of it Edgardo GGC x and it looks
fantastic they definitely come I'm just
happy that down it des T is a little bit
away from it in October I could actually
enjoy it a little bit longer before
shadow keep goes out I'm playing I'm
gonna play that with kiss me I'm kind of
worried because kids smooth kind of
rages a lot mm-hmm like I'm gonna start
playing that game with them and I have a
feeling I'm gonna in playing that game
like solo anything on games calm it got
you excited that you're looking forward
to a couple of things that kind of
popped up that I thought I was a big fan
of leave not Kerbal space program
mmm immerse I can't wait to see the the
new things that they added in the new
type of way that's working that watch
those two I'm sorry watch those legions
yeah I know you guys gonna make fun of
me but I really haven't been keeping up
with watched oh it's like
all right I believe when I started the
second one yesterday morning because I
had had say me I've had it yes kind of
bad yeah I think that's what did it for
me like I hate there's very few games
well I don't make I don't force myself
to finish any game now look like
watchdogs that last game that I forced
myself to finish and I was like never
again it's over but to to was beautiful
so it was accurate right that's what I
think about watchdog it was very
accurate but Legion dude it's now you
gonna you're gonna you're gonna get a
granny squat going those great he's
gonna kick ass was grateful now I've
seen a bunch of stuff about it but I
like the all the the way that the
communication is with your party and the
people and seeing how things are gonna
like you know end up I was like are you
gonna is this gonna be kind of like a
new type of mass effect type of genre of
game where you're gonna have like
options to pick and the options you pick
gonna depend upon us the people live
they die I'm like I think and it's
medieval times which is kind of like the
stuff I like I'm like hmm like is this
gonna be like a Kingdom Come deliverance
type game what is this gonna be and I
was just like I got I'm like I can't
wait to buy the trailer it looked very
entry I got like um vibes as far as like
yeah you know I got Inquisition vibes I
could do that custom off they'll leave
you your crew and I it surprised me I I
gotta give you agree I think shouted
Izzy he's been knowing that greed for
train for a minute and when I finally
saw that true I gotta give that up I was
definitely interested by those shoes mmm
did another one about the Companions I
like directly about the Companions and
how they operate with your wit there's a
self I'm just like mmm mmm like these
people off the leave you get actually
you have to be able to like do things to
entice them to get into your group now
aspect yeah I was I've already got a
these guys off you have to kill people
what are you gonna do is this person not
gonna be able to like try my creeper
when is the release date man we know
when it's
the middle of next month oh I think it's
I'll look it up but yeah any of you see
that any of you see that gameplay on the
outer worlds yeah I did not it looked
kind of spooky man cool I like how the
world looks fantastic yeah that's a
that's an obsidian game in the club it's
also made amazing good games yeah they
made one of my favorite they made my
favorite Fallout game but that AI in
that game in that game look bad I'm
hoping when the actual game comes out
like that
AI is improved because they were just
sitting there getting shot up like they
were try to move I'm just like mad cuz
I'm really you guys snort called me I'm
really looking forward to that game and
I when I saw that I was like your games
come coverage or anything that
specifically caught your eye which was
what you looking at the Avengers the
Avengers just wanting a better showing
yeah we are better showing a clearer
showing of what the game is I'm not sure
that I'm sold on the game but uh you
know the fact that I see what they had
to do with giving each each Avenger
their own shine and sort of like putting
them in scenarios where their specific
powers can shine I just don't know that
that's the game I only saw one like
little one but it just seems like it's
it's kind of on Rails it's very yeah and
I don't know and I was talking ACOG
about
I said if if they can if the narrative
pulls it off and the the upgrade and
skill tree is good then the fact that
it's linear it won't bother me as much
people can do the unreal thing it's just
like the rest your game has to be on
point right argue at all be honest which
I don't really think they care about
needs to get his Avenger groove on the
engine looked good after me and I've
gave it a lot it can keep you keep in
mind I saw the one that people said they
didn't like the most that was the black
little one like what I really liked
about it is like would you sit in there
give and taskmaster master that bit that
worked you know like the other Avengers
are flying and doing stuff around her
and so like I really enjoy like I still
don't like how they look I don't like
how they sound but you know I like the
boy see the problems we changed and my
hope is that you could what if you could
just switch back and forth between them
right it almost felt like you know like
everyone yeah everyone else yeah that's
what it felt like
but he went they went for that big
cinematic feel you know I'm saying up
close kind of a deal you know see who's
making it it's the same people that made
tomb Raider's so right yeah like you
said that that cinematic vibe to where
you're gonna be yeah kind of on Rails a
little bit loose but it's really gonna
be for the look of whole thing yeah yeah
you know I'm a huge boss parts to do and
when she when she knocked that
taskmaster he fell and I thought it was
over then I was like no this is over but
like there was different sections the
taskmaster fighting so like I enjoy that
like I just like in spider-man right no
we're not even talking about that
because I have to go to work today
those baby I didn't like the audio
quality of the beat so the JBL's being a
time audiophile I'm actually bring that
across for the price range that I was
working in so you can definitely get
these for under $100 they're better than
the studios in my opinion no doubt no
doubt
so anything else off that Coach just for
the weird factor death strands just can
we please just all come together this
community and be like I don't know
what's going on you know I'm still
standing by my term that you know maybe
you could Jima deserves to be in a
straitjacket like I'm just saying like I
don't mind weird because I mean control
is plenty weird it's weird and it's
confusing
not in this way like Kojima's Kojima's
I've always said this about Kojima he'll
take a simple concept and convolute it
for no reason I'm really I'm really
starting to think UNAMI kept this dude
in check good luck oh yes what better
view was that way we got today for some
part in and one of the secret people
evolved was like I'm like he just shot
now like what's going on
I think I called you brain what's funny
is like I can't really talk about
cringe-worthy dialogue anymore because I
play Kingdom Hearts the whole game just
cringe-worthy
but anyway so sobbing you still
intrigued yeah I mean and weirdly
intrigued yes I'm gonna get it cuz I
want to see did you deserve to be in a
straitjacket for saying I don't disagree
with you I set out to do said I'm
getting my art Kelly moving along I
don't really think that I think all the
stuff is like smoke and mirrors I
believe those are mocked up trailers
that he's giving out to the public to
get this conversation rolling and you're
gonna get a really straight that's crazy
yeah I just like I really I just I'm
baffled what I don't understand what's
going on and like you know people
Jonathan be put up there this is a baby
simulator Jonathan first you know I
don't read nothing unless it's in color
so that contravene listen I gotta read
Jonathan because Issa gave us a lot of
quality but I'm only gonna say this for
one reason and this throat baby's gonna
come out in its first words are gonna be
in Daryl's ears yo dude
that games good shake the bushes it's
good you know what they're gonna do copy
it enjoy it at the very end like that's
going to clothe the baby to calm it down
I'm waiting for the lawsuit I'm sorry a
soft finish yeah how this is just a
testament to how weird totem is in
general there is an article on m4t I
forgot who wrote it detailing the
history of urine in Kojima game those
are pretty much you stand out you know
the Lord King or Gamescom sir what is on
the radar
what a feeling alright so what are you
for is actually all the free stuff that
you get during the week from Microsoft
to be honest which I think Microsoft was
a little bit harder than many out of the
company even though Nintendo did release
a lot of stuff out this week as far as
demos and stuff but it was generation
zero that I got a chance to play to
speak because of games that is a highly
underlip game right now a really unique
game
yes very unique it's like fallout yes I
did say fallout you don't get angry man
in this chat now and it's for people a
drop in drop out the world it has a
story to it as a background set in the
80s so it has a stranger things type of
fail to it the game is very unique I
hope they continue to work on it because
if arrows just right it feels like it's
in pocket and frame rate the the engine
that they use in is outstanding so
that's what I took away from that part
but when I saw that destiny on a
Microsoft actually got hope because I
thought that hey bighead definitely went
[Laughter]
Superjet when he personally because all
the wacky information that we do is
coming out in like the opening scene is
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's hope he doesn't the longer he
stays with Microsoft the longer that
names gonna get is he is he is he a
husband of a murdered wife but to shut
up a lot of you people that were out
here with the burning houses and
screaming
oh the sky is falling a chicken littles
chance to see Gears of War single-leg
it's mind-blowing it's Microsoft is
working that sounds like a shot for a
specific ignored in a row you're not
part of the PR team I wanna see this now
no I'm tired of your now what you want
know what the company wants so the
company wants to roll it out they want
to show you this part first and then
that part then the meat and potatoes of
it potatoes how do you feel now so
basically keep the same energy now that
is it looked good and the campaign was
on fire and he was show no you don't
have game pass I mean for me actually
inside Xbox was solid I was actually you
know I mean a cringy still cringy humor
sometimes gets on my nerves but it's
hard to show itself what they showed you
know I liked what I saw the Blair Witch
joint pub G cross platform that was
interested in me um I wanna shout just
gota from window sensual arm when he
came on aisle P he was talking about a
game Empire of sin and I got my eye on
that man's giving me the XCOM RTF files
but also like well I wanted really
I don't know why I expected it expected
but I just want
XCOM announcements I don't care where
they come at this point I don't care if
it's games go like I just wanted X
common elements and I'll be waiting for
it to land foot you know why we XCOM
heads but yeah for me it's like yeah
Empire scene like that mark Chicago
prohibition aerial it kind of gives me
on solve like Broadwalk Empire vows yeah
like it's just cool you know yeah so I
showed real good day I was liking that
like King say yo was really good
symbolically
to see Bunji at Microsoft stage because
we know the history we know the deal
with Activision and all that stuff that
prevented the exclusive so to see light
you know home you know they're like you
know it away
you know what's coming him home yeah bad
it was kind of cool
shout out to dizzy with the two dollar
super chato Lord being petty keep Major
Nelson off inside Xbox you don't want to
see the white gloves yes I actually love
Major Nelson every time he sees me I
don't care where he is well we're on
line on a cue going inside Microsoft
what's up bro yeah I really like to show
um ii said that joint um what else
it was the oh I was leading the gears
like King said campaign being showing a
horde being shown you know say I don't
agree still don't agree King they should
have showed it at e3 they still should
have shown a little bit but I'm happy
now you know I want you know but uh was
gonna say a shot together because I
agree I was just want to say that like
the thing and notice like I'm not used
to games go I'm having this level of
spectacle you know I'm saying you got
you know I'm Bob this guy Keighley there
it almost a lot of the thumbs you don't
even know this games calm but this year
you knew Gamescom was going on
it definitely felt huge it felt epic it
felt like Howie threes supposed to feel
and I'm very curious moving forward you
know I'm saying because how this thing
is gonna go because we all know what
happened with e3 and you know the leaks
and you know that kind of had the red
carpet like the own live like the
gamescom what is it the LA premiere show
or whatever that thing was
I felt I felt like VGA I felt like you
know it was going on you know so on that
was so VGA that it was straight out to
vGHS I was good i'm hype about that
we're gonna see what a xbox has for
london it looks like they gearing up for
something with big gore-tex homeland and
i'm curious about that and then on the
last thing is exactly the last thing I
want to mention the King's gone low
nobody was out that stadium stadium was
in the building y'all stadium a stumbled
man they stumbled alright or Horace all
so we gonna have what we could have a
civil war right great work i well i
don't think they still do enough people
on this yet this is this for this is for
the guy i guess who wants that 4k 60
experience who's not at home who may
have a potato rig he's at his friend's
house he wants to move it around you
know everything not everybody has a 20
80 60 huh you think they can achieve
that
actually shout out to my man Destin Lee
Geary who will behind the scenes who got
a chance to play doom you know saying
all these gate and don't know straight
up you can put the front lawn you can
put it all you want
I don't need to pre-order yet you know
what I could wait till it's a real world
I can wait to get I don't need to jump
out the window just yet it's not
November keen wants to do what keen
wants to do is jump out the plane before
the plane I could wait it's not November
yet so anyway like I was saying he was
very impressed with what he played he
could not believe it he's been the
biggest stadia detractor and it was in
the gamescom environment all the
wireless interference you could possibly
muster and it was pretty seamless is
what he said and to be honest this is
what this is the shocker we all played x
cloud obviously you know I'm saying
previously before in on e3 close
environment you know Server 400 miles
away whatever his words were the stadia
experience at this point was smoother
and better than X cloud these were his
exact words he's the biggest ad a/d
track I feel about that case so I want
to know more but I'm curious about the
time pretty sure he does
oh my god I got rid of my pre-order do
you still have a pre-order son I don't
but I think I don't I don't want to not
be in a conversation so I'll get it back
studies actually doing something oh I
was at uh oh I think yeah I was at
McDonald's yesterday and one of my
friends he's the manager there and I was
talking to he's like
just pre-ordered stadium I was like man
I was like hearing a couple months he's
like it looks good he's a big dude you
can know I agree this is not for
everybody listen to Tech and me just
wants to see it in real-world scenario I
want to do the cross play with destiny
to see how that functionality works firm
cross play with consoles and and they
are say yes they are say cross say
excuse me cross save not cross the
crosswalk on sole so I am waiting we'll
see what happens but that's all I got on
but they might be on to something
I have to I have to speak up for King I
don't like what you just did there Lord
solve you a delta you got a lot to talk
about this you've got some access on
control man pad control since Monday I
think the review embargo is actually up
the day of you can put one up so I'm
assuming he got a mr. Lee special as
well because the game know he got that
remedy 505 game special no yes it was
today everything okay because can no big
sites have put up reviews yet which is
okay I'm not done yet if I given the
game
you wouldn't been finished with it my
name yeah well it's sorry it's up to
chapter four it's not the full game okay
oh yeah okay so yeah so I've had it
since Monday mm-hmm if you were a fan of
remedy games this is a remedy game
through and through it is a third-person
narrative driven action game mechanics
are super smooth the mechanics are
amazing I think the telekinetic powers
like as you've seen in the trailer the
one night are very cool I haven't gotten
all the powers yet I only have about
four right now my disposal but very cool
they all they all have actual uses in
combat some of them you know they're not
throw aways um especially as you start
going up against more groups of enemies
stronger enemies you're gonna need to
utilize all your different aspects of
Europe of your arsenal but the game is
it's kind of different than like a
quantum break or in that it's it's sort
of like less narrative lis driven the
game is quantum break obviously would
like the uh the the TV show attached to
it and the way the story came out it was
kind of more linear in this game the
gameplay is linear but the context the
side context that they always do in
remedy games like with all the
collectables and stuff give you more
overall context extra as to the story
and I think it's a lot more discoverable
than quantum break quantum break you can
kind of run by this stuff and not even
pay attention to it this because of the
way the game is set up it feels like
you're always gonna run into this stuff
and you're gonna get this context right
so all I can say about the game right
now in terms of story I think it is
crazy it is nuts but it's not throw baby
nuts I got to get handed off to your
right you're just something that's a
great analogy I'm gonna start using that
from now on every time someone acts like
full right okay you can't be crazy just
not baby throat nuts
that's the word story so basically a
quick overview not spoiling anything the
story revolves around Jesse fading who
are basically this world is subject is
subject to like what they call
paranormal like occurrences like
occurrences that basically kind of
indicate that there is a world beyond
there are world kind of like a parallel
universe or even a supernatural universe
but it has a very sci-fi tinge to it so
it could be supernatural it could be
very but they sort of try to ground it
in science um so basically she is drawn
to this place um trying to find clues as
to what happened to her brother a long
time ago because they experienced one of
these uh sort of Perrin actual events
when they were young and her brother was
taken away by this organization called
the Federal Bureau of control basically
it is it is an ax men and black sort of
organization that is basically exist to
sort of study and analyze and control
these perón actual occurrences or Alize
mataji's that's gonna happen right in a
beginning like you're not gonna so
basically she makes her way to this - to
this Bureau and finds and realizes that
things have gone left and basically the
story is her figuring out what's going
on and trying to figure out what
happened to her brothers that's the
extent of the story in terms of the
action like like Danny Tosh says
[Music]
[Music]
a couple weeks ago
say start I was talking about halo 5
likes us I'm like look if you ain't
playing fire by now that's not being
that um I felt that the quantum break
had the Vaseline Edition on the regular
Xbox that was before the ex came out
what what does it look like
how's the revolution what's the
framerate what's going on no framerate
is dirty resolutions 4k no HDR support
what play are you playing on the excerpt
oh yeah yeah no HDR support um so if you
have you have a juiced up rig you have
an RT X card I was just playing it on
that because you're gonna get all that
nice RTX goodness and all that all those
extra effects and whatnot it looks good
on the X ray summer yeah he said he
pre-ordered on ps4 because he against
his missing content heating about their
missing content life what what exclusive
do they have doing I don't know honestly
I got on the X ray I don't know what
specifically it might be a mission or
two or something like that okay or
something I know this specific pre-order
content ever version you get Oh was
gonna get that on PlayStation regardless
[Music]
so yeah so in terms of the story that's
that's what I'm gonna say about the
story to the powers like Danny Todd says
the powers are all very cool they're all
sort of telekinetic powers where you
know you can levitate things that throw
them at people
you can also what the heck else you can
do you can speed up you can you you can
sort of levitate you can you can grab
stuff from the environment and use it as
a shield you can control enemies at some
point you know once you damage them to a
certain point you
control them also once you M's them to a
certain point you can grab them and
actually chuck them at other enemies as
well um the gunplay - I thought I always
had an issue with the gunplay in quantum
break I didn't think it was as tight as
other remedy games I think the gunplay
is absolutely great in this and the fact
that there's cooldowns on both the
powers and the gunplay means that you
have to go back and forth between both
of those so you can't like spam like you
can spam about the part one gun right
it's one good item morphs into others so
you don't have to worry about like
picking up other guns and picking up
ammo and stuff like that it's one it's
like part of your powers which is pretty
cool yeah the gun no I haven't played it
since since since Guardian con but I've
been looking at it and been talking I'm
talking about guys about it and every so
it reminds me a lot of if you've ever
played an old game called like a
PlayStation 1 or 2 game called psyops
exactly like that but an updated version
of it and I'll tell right now I had a
lot of fun with with with control and I
almost fell asleep - what was with the
other remedy gamers talking about oh you
don't need nyquil just by quantum break
watch you name you the main character
from quantum break Iseman alright so you
know that that that that studio was open
for that game right and they had to use
them in that area and it was a different
direction for a different company you
can see the change from that to this so
I really want to know because I really
like quantum break as far as the game
playing the fun goes but I thought it
was bogged down with the story I should
say it's just not my style of game
misstep with with the
TV series thing I think it was just I
think it was that and I think it was
horribly paste yeah that game got
changed from some type of game that was
supposed to work in tandem with a
television show and then it got it was
just so many things that I was doing a
damn matric error there's so many mind
amorphousness of that game I think that
affected the final product that's just
an integral to what I heard mmm oh they
did the same thing yes
what was that name yes Arase no it was a
it was a text I know what you talked
about it was a show they're supposed to
be it's like content based on the I'm
forgetting the Nate I can visualize it
if I have it I can't buy it I was
actually because I actually played that
on the 360 and I was trying to remember
what it was called
yes actually I think they canceled that
show because they don't do it doesn't do
well so I was wondering when quantum
break came out and they started talking
I was like why are they doing this it
didn't work well I just think at that
time it was the TV era that was to try
to integrate everything into one yes and
it just didn't work out well like I
don't not even blame it I'm blaming like
50/50 on that that's what 2% Microsoft
and remedies fault because remedy should
have pushed back more I'm putting the
blame because that's an amazing show it
was a very good show right so you had
you know somebody sitting in Microsoft
exaction they put that game could you
imagine that we have these dudes with
our studio we can definitely top some
and Sony was you know I got a really
gave King Pross man he's not only do not
know they could turn everything into
Sony's fall that's still I can never
have my life
that was good they need to get kijima to
do a TV show oh I know you guys get into
it with the control did I just want to
ask like you know so I promise you I
played a behind the scene um and what
Scotty 3 was it that last year but the
year before when 505 was showing it and
you know I definitely device but he
definitely had its own thing but now
shout the dreamcast guy who just put her
view up he is really praising this thing
man he's like 0.5 he is just like this
is the essence type stuff so and your
opinion like do they got one is it it's
dis - sleeper hit um based on what I've
seen of the story so far and the power
that I've gotten so far and the way
everything works together yeah I think
yeah I think it's very good
oh I don't I want to see how it all
comes together I'm obviously I think I
guess he's finished it
yes I'm like he's asked so that remains
to be seen but it I said it's definitely
a remedy game and I think that the the
issues you guys have a quantum break of
the same ones I have about the pacing
and how this how the TV show threw it
all off in this game it's it's a much
less cinematic game than quantum break
so what happens is that you're you're
sort of forced as you go through the
game you're going to see all these
collectibles that actually pertain to
the overall story anything you don't
like
if you want me to collect stuff first
off you gotta make an audio version
because I ain't reading nothing problem
with the you you see Dan oh that's why
your strategy guys went out cuz this kid
these kids they don't read that's the
problem Channel
I actually said that I bought the
stretchy they just said oh that's gonna
visually show me what they're talking
about
trust me you know many people ask me if
my twitch book was a audiobook and then
when I said no they're like oh I guess
I'm not reading that when you said it
was on Amazon I almost asked you audio
[Music]
you got to do the audio version ten
dollar super chat quantum break they did
take a lot of risk in in and they did
try to do something new and always and I
always appreciate that sometimes it
doesn't always hit but I still think the
quantum break was a great game I think
that I respect the statement quantum
break I thought was cool I think the the
whole story arc with the girl that gets
quite just was was fantastic I felt like
a quantum break was just like if it was
developed like a normal game from start
to finish it would have been a great
game yeah played control I could even
finish quantum break dude because it was
just that bad like but this is what you
do right you go by control right now
because this is what happens when you
take absolutely all the funding for the
cinemas out let's produce the game out
my issues my issues with the game so far
maybe this will be rectified in a day
one patch um every time you come out of
a pause mm-hmm it did it does a nice
little stutter step every time you come
out of a pause um but it cleans up and
then it runs fine um also when you're in
a big combat scenario where you're using
a lot of powers and you're facing
multiple enemies it starts to stutter
[Music]
we're not gonna let that rhetoric girl
you say are you safe as made on a
Playstation program kid that's what's
going on here it was the least common
denominator okay you might be on yeah I
really want to see how people react to
this game like I said it's weird but
it's not over the top here it is
definitely understandable
I think story that they've crafted is
very good I think remedies always been
good at crafting worlds that that adhere
to specific rules according to the story
they're trying to tell I think they've
done that again with this well I just
don't I want they had they're capable
they their games don't ever scream like
Uncharted Last of Us triple a quality
it's it's it always feels like it's a
little it because of this if you're not
a fan of these games and you're you're
gonna play through this once maybe twice
that's it okay um you can the way the
powers you pick you can focus on certain
powers and not necessarily focus on
other ones so you can kind of play
around with your skill tree in that
regard where a different second
playthrough might be different but it's
not that that varying what you'd be like
it's gonna be like a totally different
game first guys alright no it's
confirmed solve just said this is a game
pass game continued though before should
still be excited for it I think what I
always try to backtrack I think what
they've done and and the improvements
they made over quantum break and
everything else they've come out with
obviously Max Payne and things
I think this is the next evolution of
remedy and I I'm doing edition preview
[Laughter]
we got two towers we got a roll all
right so I'm up so uh Xbox game studios
man a lot going on right now and uh
Microsoft jumped in front of the
headlines at Gamescom and basically
started with our Aaron Greenberg and
offering to the brown and pretty much he
said that um yes I'm gonna caught up
what I'm they pretty much say you know
going forward all of our internal
studios and the new studios we added
will be focused on making games for our
platforms and I quote we have no plans
to expand our exclusive first party
games to any other consoles so this was
a huge statement kind of too early the
week a lot of the Xbox community rally
behind it because I you know a lot of
the concern was you know obviously we've
seen Ori and the blind forest on switch
we've seen you know carpet and people
were concerned they were like you know
obviously out of worlds we you know we
know about be going to switch as well
like people concern are these studios
truly exclusive to Xbox you know and
then you know so that was early in a
week and then later in the week we had
some statements from Microsoft's Ben
Dekker and Matt Percy from marks off
about the future of game pass and then
they said you know about the
subscription model you know we would
like to see game pass on all platforms
ultimately and I think that this is a
long-term goal so we don't have any
specific plans today but we love to see
game paths really go everywhere so I
want to bring this to the Lords I want
to shout out Lord Randolph door just
gonna had a great discussion on this on
the Xbox two in reference to Microsoft
messaging on one hand we hear the games
are not going anywhere there remain on
Xbox but other hand we hear game fast we
our goal is to go everywhere what's
going on so I want to bring this to Lord
Daniel Tosh first what do you think
about this
yeah we got to get everyone before King
because he was yeah so yeah you have I
mean it sounds like Microsoft to me
I mean the memo they open the Microsoft
rate right they don't they decree pretty
great things they created the worst OS
in the entire universe but everybody has
to use it because they have they have
patented DirectX the point is they're
the slowest moving tech company in the
entire world
mmm yet they still come out with great
stuff which is why we keep forgiving
giving them but this is just it's
communication error I don't know what
they probably mean the same thing mm-hmm
but they're not communicating that
properly I think they mean because I
think what they mean by all their
platforms expanding out to all their
platforms is just saying Xbox and PC
which is why I like the game pass cuz I
can get game pass without even ever
turning on my my xbox and being able to
stamps are free mmm but I kind of think
that's what they mean cuz he got because
not only you have Xbox your Xbox one X
you've got a PC and then you have
whatever Scarlett's gonna be right so
that might be what they're talking about
when they're talking about that I don't
think they're necessarily hinting or
talking about the switch or talking
about the PlayStation because internally
I'm sure that they don't even they don't
mention Sony at all they don't Nintendo
at all they don't they don't those are
the words don't even come into their
lips because they don't really it's not
part of the conversation so I don't
think that's that's what the second
person really meant so let me ask you
this like that before I move on you know
because a lot of points of contention
and Xbox fans have and even Sony fans
will say is that you don't look these
games are not exclusive why is you know
cuphead going on switch why is re going
on switch you know now again Greenberg
did jump in front of it and he said look
they are respecting existing deals you
know at prior to these guys acquisition
right so do you think it's strictly that
or do you think at some point they truly
envision a world where they want game
pass on all these platforms yeah I think
it is that
they I think Microsoft because they own
Windows they can get away publicly and
through their PR channels they could get
away with being 100% exclusive because
if you look at who's complaining about
what there's actually like especially in
these days maybe back in like
PlayStation 3 playstation 4 xbox 360
Xbox one releases there was a lot of
talk about oh this games exclusive to
this console this games exclusive this
console but now that like pcs are
becoming more and more affordable and
gaming PC's are more more affordable
staying exclusive to both Xbox and Pete
and PC and and then Scarlett those three
and keeping them there they can get away
with that without getting too much flack
and being totally okay with it
I really do think that they want to live
in a world where everything is exclusive
to them Lord PD we got to get you in man
what do you think about these statements
is bad messaging or do you what you
believe it's going to happen it's it's
actually I when I heard you give us this
topic I actually like you know I wrote a
little thing down and literally Danno
said it's when they're talking about
platforms I don't know I think they're
talking about like what he was saying
going to Xbox don't want a PC you know
going to all of those just makes logical
sense for them you know please station
like they do the same thing they they're
exclusive games but they only have one
platform so for Xbox to say like you
know what they said it means all of this
all of their stuff which you know and if
I do recall - aren't they putting game
pass on switch - and they took well
there were early rumors that there may
be something working with Nintendo but
then they kind of backtracked
so for whatever reason nothing is
finalized enough it's official right so
which means I think that they're gonna
put stuff in game pass and they're gonna
start sharp off would start putting
stuff you know and on other platforms in
quotes you know right through that means
and methods so that people are to start
buying it that way but III think that
you know the from what I've read they
have their twelve gaming Studios which
is exclusive to them if games which I
think are coming out within the next
year or two and you know like you were
saying you
feels that they have on some of those
games are gonna be stacking but I I
don't see why they're gonna keep
themselves 100% exclusive
unless then you're some weird method of
doing it and getting it out and I think
that they're gonna use game pass to do
it and I think that's what they're gonna
do this to put it on to other platforms
and force people to buy game pass
because that is where I think that
they're making their money that's that's
what they're doing with their services
so it forced that method then it makes
logical sense that makes smart lord
addict I know you're getting ready to
leave soon so we're gonna get you in arm
what do you feel about this man is it
bad messaging is it smacks of lying
what's going on in I feel like it's just
one of those things where you know in
that particular department I don't know
if there's a PR person around you know
Aaron Greenberg does nothing but
relations with so he's really good at PR
so you know I don't think that they
misspoke cuz I do think eventually you
know they wanted to go on an app form
right you know but that's like maybe
five ten years down the road I don't
think they misspoke but I do think that
you know when you need to clarify
something they should have they should
have made a statement or something by
now to correct this because it was
trending and everything yeah
like especially cuz all it looks it
makes you look like you're competence
but you know they could they could be
speaking the same language but someone
you know it's it's kind of like how how
English is so weird in different forms
around the world like you know certain
people say certain phrases differently
but it you know they might be they're
saying the exact same thing but in
different ways right yeah so people
would and then you have a third party
that doesn't know the language on both
sides so they're seeing it two different
ways
mhm oh oh okay good
so you know it just they they really
need to set everyone down in that PR
department in that marketing part and
they're like they need to really have
that conversation what are we talking
about what it what do we say to people
because apparently this is the first
time this has happened yeah
I hear that man is definitely definitely
something probably needs to be resolved
internally so they all know Saint pray
Lord solve what do you feel man
confusion which belief I'm a new addict
I mean I really need to say I don't
believe that they don't have these
conversations that's that's the weird
thing I believe these conversations
happen it's just reason you know when
you're out there you know you're being
asked on the spot I think I know Phil is
really good at not answering questions
while answering a question like me I
don't know the Aaron Aaron's always been
the type of dude that sort of like he's
he's in the moment you know I know he's
a marketing guy obviously this is his
job day in and day out but it just
seemed like for whatever reason I can't
believe those could that communication
isn't happening it's just different way
it's happening it's just not with these
people they're talking to their bosses
like I really think that you know
they're letting the people that don't
have that experience talking like that
in a mass forum like that talk the most
what the crazy thing is okay we look at
a Matt booty Matt booty comes out and
says it's gonna be on a game by game
basis does that like so which which is
the issue what is happening that we
don't see these issues with Sony right
we don't see it other companies they
seem to be a unified front for the most
part with whatever they're trying to
mess about
why would Microsoft it seems to be one
hand is saying one thing it's like is
there a communication issue internally
maybe like let's be honest here maybe
it's that Microsoft don't know what they
want to do in the future and they keep
changing stuff up on people and I agree
with that I totally agree that they you
know depending on the success of Xbox as
a platform going into next gen I think
you know I think the narrative changes
they'll lean more into console of the
console successful and only more more
and more into services if the services
are what's more more successful or where
content is it begins to fail um so I
think they leave that door open for
themselves so then it's a fluid
situation which is a good situation that
they got out in front of because at this
point they don't want it to see
fluid situation right now
if things go left hmm Oh our games
aren't going to other platforms is not
sticking that doesn't Lord King here we
go I can already tell you I'm probably
going safe for Kings over at but I will
stay as long as I can there's an app
it's called game right now this is going
to lead you in all right so Microsoft
already got these guys hooked on the
juice to servers definitely in hey now
we know we waiting for X cloud to come
out to be able to facilitate these games
once they link it with game past and you
have X cloud now you have an
underpowered system like the switch that
can actually run an Xbox game so but it
can do it if it actually has game paths
with X cloud enabled on it
resident app right so we all know
internally yes a like shut out the green
where's the wool for getting in front of
it to put water on the fire right which
was a great statement I thought was yes
that's his job to put water on the fire
but in the background those other two
guys heard his speech of world dominance
and said we want our joint on everything
I want to know on the toaster so they
disobey greedy is this it wasn't this
will be greeny greeny window and put
listen this is gonna happen it's just
not happening right now because these
dudes ain't ready yet you don't have the
x-ray now they would ideally love
to have game pass on playstation why not
let's stop with all this oh I don't want
Xbox stuff on my stuff or I want the
game pass everything like I saw them
playing games inside a car yeah like a
tablet out yes right they want that
everywhere right are you guys
understanding know there's no limit that
they will both right mm-hmm
greenie was saying calm down hmm not
right now right calm down
the other guys were remembering other
speech of world domination on your
Playstation if it's permissible later
when they worked a deal if they work -
6040 deal the hell they working mmm it's
gonna happen game pass is going to be
all over sold everybody on the panel is
right when they say Microsoft right now
was talking about their level of devices
they have control over right that they
won game pass on right right that's
logical right of course
do you want them to say as a company we
do not want to expand to the PlayStation
get yourself over on that switch it's
not taking away from the fact that you
have your box and it plays best ear -
two questions so basically you're saying
that he's using flexible language so no
plans right now right you know the
question I have for you kid the next
argument is if that is the case it like
you said world domination then what
happens now like what do people say like
well I don't have a reason to buy the
Xbox platform anymore because all of
their
Oh bye-bye the game pass or wherever you
play
buy a game pass yes what you give the
money to Microsoft if you want to lock
yourself into your PlayStation and still
game past what does it doesn't matter
Microsoft them dollars one thing we're
not talking about though we Sony has a
fast like year-and-a-half alone has a
large track record of not wanting to
cross with anybody right they they don't
want to work with absolutely anybody so
it's it's less about more about
expansion PlayStation logging into your
PlayStation and game pass you register
there the principle would step down
because except gay pass on detects funny
already restored I just think
PlayStation would never allow it because
they will become a money-making machine
for Microsoft interesting
it's risky no let me finish about this
joy um yeah listen at the end of the day
I would you say a cake I hate everyone
Lords are saying it's just messaging man
they gotta get it together you know say
to me this is what lost him to start a
generation no one knows if they doing
the DRM are they doing it Kenya tre
games and then Sony did what Sony did
and we know what the rest is history
with the ps4 era you know at the end of
the day you gotta be clear even if it's
world domination is they're gonna say
this done that no games coming right
right they're gonna say no games coming
and then later down the road a game
might come if it comes this is the
statement they're gonna point to you're
a liar you said that it what happened
now so why not just get in front of it
they want to keep their options open my
case they changed their mind in the
future but so they can't be called out
for but he said this know we had mixed
messaging sure but we never clarified
anything here's the problem if we are
the hard core right everyone on this
panel is a hard call we know what's
going on a game if we're confused on
what's going on at what side they're on
what do you think little Timmy or casual
Joe is thinking he doesn't why does it
always gotta be Timmy - OH - yeah Tony
for marketing Calvin Calvin I just like
I said I just want them that so that
everyone knows what's going on because
if someone spreads like hey Mac you all
the Microsoft games are gonna be
everywhere and that ends up not being
true then that right okay yes that's the
thing so that's just a marketing on it I
got a bill
right now I got your brother go for it
so we got a $5 super chat from restored
Hades I just think the PlayStation would
never allow it because they would become
a money-making machine for Microsoft I
think that's good screen just refresh
and he gave it to you I just think solve
like next gen is so critical for them
and I just want them to get off to the
right start I think God Halo infinite at
launch you and I'm saying this just this
is marketing messaging doubt there's no
there's no hate on any individual person
I think it's legitimately just there's
confusion going on and I think
communication is not necessarily clear
it's not bad it's just not quickly
that's always people are free literally
afraid because we went to this
generation wrong God - [ __ ] I ain't
scared of nothing if it was not leading
us into this next war from what's coming
forward you know I would definitely be
afraid okay now knowing and I told
people ahead of time mm-hmm this guy has
a control on it if you have to know how
to manage your team but now we've said
it before and listen I'm compromised
i'ma let you know right yeah you're
compromised okay yeah yeah my dude is
greenie okay so I am completely
compromised and bias and anything that I
will be saying thank you for the no turn
that on for me right now okay yeah we
having a problem with the messaging
right and everybody wants it to be
buttoned down and clean what addict is
on to is there being ambiguous with the
messaging on purpose probably having
stuff
with the ink is still wet Arden they're
just waiting for a signature to have
this here go by what map guty said mmm
it's a game the game basis and we'll see
if our games fit in that ecosystem a lot
of games from Microsoft has made it onto
different platforms in different forms
now you have games that's coming out and
they will respect other prior
commitments that they had to other games
and Studios going forward like that uh
what game is that that's gonna be
released out of out of worlds yeah
everywhere all right
that's a Microsoft company you have to
understand its business they don't come
out and tell you it's business bro
because everybody wants to feel safe or
secure and they purchase go buy that but
if blue do you say one thing and then
Greenberg said another bigger dead bees
Percy and this guy said three different
state makes it is at a span of a week
it's bet you being a day could get in
the room and say yo fam this is what we
doing for this game calm like how have
you not they literally said on Tuesday
or whatever greedy said this on Thursday
it's like what Microsoft at this point
if I was Microsoft a little book less
you PR you've been trained to PR do not
like these do should be someone should
silence the mic shut his mic off he
can't talk let these guys talk target
they actually and what he's trying to
say is he's gonna gear state of mind
anyway we move on we're going crazy like
we
Oh solve obvi sobs a king Sony man Oh
real quick would he jump on the
insomniac they're only acquired a sonic
and then Sony Studios just made it the
worst purchase all right we not always
thought of Sonic was actually part of
Sony to be honest with you go ahead when
I thought they got out of the deal when
they did sunset overdrive or something
like that but apparently they would
never purchase for it would never
purchase with Sony now Sony went out
there and purchased the studio Microsoft
was on a buying spree Sony is on a
buying spree as well they out there
loading their guns again ready
generation of fact and I thought that
was a perfect marriage anyway they made
all the games for Sony anyway they felt
the first party studio anyway when they
made sunset overdrive the reason why I
didn't sell well over there that's
because Microsoft isn't used to perk or
marketing insomniac type of games okay
and it was a great game Kisame AK was
still in the game perfect form
in doing so they showed you when they
hit they strive with spider-man and I
thought it was a perfect purchase going
forward sony has wonderful chamber but
also you guys may not know they make a
ton of VR games yes and I think they
were purchased with that in mind because
next generation Sony is betting heavy on
VR what do you guys know download an
antenna what do you feel about the
insomniac acquisition well I know
there's a lot of insomniac games in the
game past right like all the Arkham
Arkham games and didn't they do no that
was different yet never mind um but I
think yeah I I was kind of always under
the impression is insomniac very much
and Sony have always kind of had a small
marriage together because they've they
promoted all their games pretty heavily
mm-hmm
you know spider-man was a huge one but I
mean Tom niak has been doing games like
that for a while I don't know it seems
like it it seems like a fine buy it
seems like they're going to be doing a
lot of things that really isn't much
different than just other than possibly
more exclusives for Sony which is which
is good for them I think
it's a smart buy it's a safe buy for
sure it's not anything it's gonna blow
anybody away
absolutely shadow a middle a monster
with the file a super chat difference is
Microsoft had insomniac with a new IP
Sony had insomniac with an established
Marvel character which one's going to
sell more we're not talking about that
[Music]
move by Sony I would say yes or no yes
because you know this is an established
brand that they've worked on to no
because they're literally making the
same games they've been making for them
right I think you know Microsoft buying
Studios like a nun's Microsoft buying
Studios like Ninja Theory obsidian like
I think that's a bigger news because
they weren't making exclusive right
right right so like you're literally
taking from another stable and breeding
horses to your stable
Odie's really just buying the stable
okay you know fine and I think that's
what it was is you know as much as I
hate to say it spider-man sold well they
needed to they needed to they needed to
make sure no one could buy that studio
know don't know what I think I think
King brought up a great point like I
went to their website and the first
thing you see is storm land which is an
oculus rift big title it was beautiful
so I think they yeah I think they want
to push VR really hard with my company
yeah fair enough
Lord PD and then loss of but what do you
feel about the inside I'll be quick um
Sony pretty much was there I think their
fourteenth studio the neighbor so
insomniac from their big titles that I
can remember like Ratchet and Clank
spyro yeah like that I mean weren't they
over there anyway I'm pretty much had
that relationship it which is kind of
like I would say the biggest thing that
they have for buying this is this gonna
be a huge like job once
oh we stole my point publish my stew the
first one they don't only in a game
because of all the releases from
insomniac yeah yeah no doubt Lord solve
yeah I mean I think obviously it makes
the most sense they've been they've been
essentially married to them for the
longest time they've had the biggest
success with them um but I do think when
sunset overdrive but I think insomniac
has always liked their independence and
mom but they I think they were always
been open to that conversation and I
think if there had been a different
Microsoft a different different sort of
thinking at Microsoft when sunset
overdrive came out on the Xbox hmm you
they they might have missed out on the
opportunity to perhaps show them that
they cared about that IP they really
wanted to grow that in nurture that and
they might have had an opportunity to
pick them up back then mm-hmm but if
there's something changed and they could
have bought them but they chose not to
like the Bioware do you think the
landscape would be different if
spider-man never came out it's
interesting no I don't think it would be
different I mean the Sony's success it's
you know regardless of spider-man I mean
it still is full up in the stratosphere
but I think and some there it's always
been successful they've always been
successful but I think we would have
Dean either another new IP from them on
Xbox or the sequel to sunset overdrive
right so yeah it would have looked a
little bit different I don't think it
affects so any success at all and I
don't think it really affects Microsoft
success apartment that they do have they
would have had another team they could
give you a solid single narrative action
experience do you think they did to like
prevent them from like selling like
another type of spider-man game to
Microsoft so it was just like a straight
up hey we're doing this to protect our
us but we gotta admit the successes of
writing man had to influence a little
bit of that you know definitely
influence on the purchase price that's
right you know what I was saying I'm
saying on Twitter I was like you know
I've been crazy this would never happen
but this scenario would be hilarious
that this microphone let's say more well
gets real penny over this stuff and they
pull the rice
and they give that to Microsoft and
Microsoft makes spider-man sue and they
make subset over John despite Microsoft
before you know the launch title for the
next-gen it's sunset overdrive - on
PlayStation spider-man - hilarious no
real incident another Australian
quote-unquote fight Microsoft mm-hmm I
could see a remedy purchase we never we
never had them we had the same
relationship didn't Sonia cat with me
right right and once again they show
they they didn't nurture them really and
say you know what we believe in it so
much we want to bring you into the fold
right well success I mean the final
sales of the game also probably dictated
to that a little bit right but I would
say this yeah we have ladies again okay
shout to restore Hayes at $10 super chat
I think this Sony finally bought
insomnia because they were afraid that
was Google and running out here buying
studios I think they were just afraid of
someone else would get them first in it
that is absolutely true I mean Mike
installs been on a purchasing spree
Google obviously has has the wallet out
as well you know if the money's right I
mean I think insomniac has always been
one of the bigger independent studios
and more successful so I don't feel that
they were they're a type of studio this
one game away from shutting the doors
you know one bad game away from getting
the door shut on them you know when
somebody drops the bag in front of you
and it's a pretty big bag and you know
that you're not gonna be worrying about
where the money for your next move hmm
what's up it's like I said you know a
lot of people a lot of people like keep
saying stuff like oh you know this
studio is not not looking to sell that
Steve he's not looking to sell this
shows and playground has shown that
every studio so they they games they
hold company if you give the right bed
the right baggage the right price
everybody that'll be remember every
Lord King I gotta go you guys bye late
attic everyone coming on down oh it was
a pleasure to meet you I gotta go yeah
okay King we'll wrap up then I'll close
out yeah it's just the fact that you
know it was a good purchase all the way
through as is well thought out I believe
the VR played a bigger role in the
acquisition more than people will
understand you know when this deal is
all said and done and the games come out
I think they will produce more VR games
and it would produce more party
single-player or multiplayer games yeah
nothing I mean we definitely know but we
feel that VR is gonna be a big focus for
PlayStation 5 as well they look they
want to continue that you know just jump
up on what you saying we're all out arm
yeah I just think it's a Power Move I
think it's a strong move I think that
Sony is ready for war you know obviously
they see that Microsoft's making all
these studio acquisitions I think it's a
smart move they've already had the
relationship it's cool
you know um spider-man we gotta say you
know it has to have some some effect on
that I do feel Sony's petty will be out
with sunset overdrive - I definitely
think that's coming and Xbox pants
better get ready because I think it's
going out the cycle with the - our super
chat some saw sunset came at a time when
everyone hated Microsoft interesting I
mean it just said that I just felt that
you know insomniac wanted to do the
sequel and it couldn't happen you know
me myself personally I think it's kind
of like the diametric era during that
whole signing and I think if you know
Phil was a little bit more of all maybe
that didn't happen and now that he's in
a more of a position of power at the
table you know things are different I
don't think they were to purchase time
to be honest which I don't think they
fit inside Microsoft wheelhouse I do
believe Microsoft was bought at the time
and I do believe it was affecting sales
of otherwise great game to be honest
with my last point it's just like I
think next gen is the content war solve
I think it's all about how much content
and you're seeing all these studios
everyone's being acquire everyone's
gearing up because that's gonna be the
thing I think the system is gonna be
comparable I think stream is gonna be
big for Microsoft
you know how they hand like what
cloud I think also you got a PlayStation
with PS Vita they're gonna continue
pioneer in that space each has their own
little reproach but content is king so
you've got to lock these in and like
dizzy sitting in chat
I do believe our stadia again much of
people don't like them no not into a
streaming future they're aggressive and
have the capital enough to acquire
studios so at this point Sony you got a
secure the home team bring them in your
[Music]
[Music]
evil Saluda show we could get the poll
get out of here new il pipo to finish up
with the recent announcement of
Microsoft initially stating they have no
plans for releasing first party titles
on other consoles while later saying
they were like to see gay past titles on
all platforms which statement do you
believe to be closer to the truth
the choices are a Xbox first party
exclusives will remain on Xbox stop
fear-mongering B Xbox first party games
will eventually be on all platforms open
your eyes
Oh see I don't care I'm PC master-race
and I'll have all their games anywhere
an absolute pleasure to have you awesome
I know we kept your long mane but thank
you so much for sticking through all of
our man absolute pleasure wakin if I
people find you what do you got going on
you can find me everywhere a day no ties
I've got that that brand recognition is
everywhere man less energy dawg so yeah
YouTube twitch I have a thing on mixer
I've been on mixer I've been the Indian
make stuff like that
Instagram Facebook which Twitter all of
its all day no ties do you if you put
Dan Tosh in the thing and if it's not me
well like contact me I'm everywhere Dan
Tosh and stream every every evening or
sometimes very early in the morning when
snail lady's working up absolute
pleasure to hear your history journey
the strategy guys had us we could have
talked to you about that tremendous man
absolute pleasure thank you for joining
around man so much Lord no man
introduced me to this gentleman right
here man it was great to have him on a
row
way Kedah find people find you what's
going on with the stream team lead me so
so as per usual it's now though on
everything if you need me I'm always on
discord as per for the past couple of
weeks we've been discussing it we we
always want more streamers to join us on
our ILP channel so if you guys are
looking to do that please just hit me up
on discord I am pretty much always on it
and I live on the thing so hit me up
there dad or Twitter or whatever you
want um you know I'm stream every night
7:00 to 7:00 to 10:00 or 11:00 whatever
I'm in the mood for and on my on my
channel and you know I hope you first
look Empire I try to do as many as
possible so I don't have to have the
other you know members of the ILP team
which would be like a better why did
Pete give me this code because this is
horrible
so I usually take out the old schools
now he's very interested in a game so if
we if you do want to pull that one he
would be interested that's my man yes
see I try I try to hit up as many as
many people as many developers as I
possibly can during the week and you
know sometimes we get something
sometimes we don't so appreciate you
brother
we appreciate you don't know from and
it's work
at the shows will does always helping us
out one of the best cameraman in the
business mom yes
Lin why she was a blast I can't wait but
I'm in San Diego so I'll be at twitchcon
if anybody's showing up come on boy no
doubt one of these days are gonna make
it to New York Comic Con control hello
New York you got a full outfit
absolutely yeah King obedia for show you
already know will definitely break
through a big dinner come on
absolutely Lord at Sovereign Lord
sovereign still remains what is going on
the control master man what you got
going on that's it man just control I'm
gonna hopefully try to forget that
hopefully try to finish that this week
leading up to
oh my gosh Amy's co-op shaving you know
that's not true but it's funny because
we we stopped playing at the part where
they were practicing the escape from
jail yeah climbing up there climbing up
this like tunnel but - but like you
gotta go in unison like yeah yeah yeah I
know exactly the part you talking about
that's funny
yeah control this week leading up to the
end of the week man we have astral chain
well we have Blair Witch coming like
there's some stuff that's what is
control a fax fax your Lord King he did
say that that's not with the you are not
onto something you are not
Oh
[Laughter]
IOP is sponsored by about you before we
even got you you were always in my
ecosystem and I just really didn't even
know it I mean you were formulating a
lot of my gaming opinions for being very
integral in my gaming development to be
honest with you seriously
I think so I think I think we're to
connect it that way because we all all
the Lords we would go to gate that was
part of the culture you you bought the
game reserved it hey for extra-low
deserve you get that strategy got
there's no doubt in our mind king that
we have read Lord Donatella strategy my
comp we've had it we've had ownership I
know
effect definitely know for a fact you
affected me through that you appreciate
you sir and it was a damn pleasure
having you on the show today trust me
when I'm telling you everything from the
mustache to the fantastic I appreciate
everything about you thank you so much
for showing up today I appreciate the
time man yeah when they are gay I'll get
you guys out some copies of some good
guys oh dude that's for you that's
better man you already know little
cockney no Twitter please hit that like
subscribe all that good stuff a chat was
absolutely phenomenal today thank you
guys so much it was lit just want to
make a quick announcement real quick we
have a new member latest addition to the
of gaming dotnet writing team my man the
macho man himself lord hector romerez
salute that's brother he's got some
articles up right now lords of gaming
dotnet you know we went to welcome to
the team he's done some work for our
comic book resource if you're calm he's
done some freelancing there and um yeah
man he's really tremendous we're glad to
have him on board and of course all the
other writers Lord mods with the tanks
Josh reading daniel meg on those condor
lord pd himself with his division
articles always spectacular when we get
those and of course the old cheese
addicts with the reviews kings with king
of statues saw putting up IOP with needs
to even though he missed last week but
I'm not gonna throw him on the bun I'm
not gonna but he missed last week make
sure you tune in this week I have a
custom statue that's coming in okay
wraps coming at me babe is Cognito wear
glasses you wear it is sugary these are
ganas baby
this is gamers MLG I'm professional
waiting ma'am I'm try to get that gonna
sponsorship is selling out Danna we were
working on sponsorship a Guzman help us
out right now check out the last word
woody boxes we had a good wood bed
everybody please enjoy your Sunday we
are audience peace